[Music]
today marks italy's
venice italy's 1600th birthday but there
is little to celebrate the once thriving
tourist destination
along with much of the country of italy
is in lockdown as a third wave of the
pandemic
sweeps across europe chris livesay joins
us now from
the city of canals chris good morning to
you
well good morning you know venice loves
festivities think of
carnival but right now because of covid
and so few people around well it's hard
for venetians to sing
happy birthday
16 candles that is if each candle
equals a century and for the past three
centuries the history of venice has been
told
through cups of espresso in saint mark's
square at the cafe florian says its
artistic director stefano stipitic
so even casanova came here
the florian also just had a birthday
it's 300th
making it the oldest cafe in italy but
just like venice it isn't celebrating i
mean this says
everything doesn't it
this is the situation we're in he says
all of venice is on top of the tables
it's a disaster since the pandemic
venice has gone from one extreme
to the other tens of thousands of daily
tourists
many in cruise ships used to barrage the
city and distressed the locals
once even slamming into a pier today
all gone taking 90 percent of the city's
revenue with them
but in sixteen hundred years of
venetians sailing the seas
covid is hardly their first bout with
disease
venice even gave us the term quarantine
or quarantine an italian for the 40-day
period that sailors had to spend on this
island
in self-isolation to keep them from
spreading the plague
the black death as it was known gave
birth in the 17th century to this
haunting doctor's mask
the long nose ensuring social distancing
says costume designer stefano nicolao
so this is like ppe this is like the
mask and the gloves
that we have to wear today yeah because
of color quite simply the venetians have
seen it all before
it says mayor luigi bruniado
tourists will come back but we'll have
to manage them more responsibly
and if a city as important as venice can
bounce back he says
then so can the rest of the world
now check this out right now in st mark
square hardly anyone in sight now
for the next several months festivities
are planned but it's anyone's guess
if they'll actually be held and if there
will be any tourists around
to see them tony all right chris and
venice italy for us chris thank you very
much i see my reaction time to venice
lover and
mason exactly i'm desperate to go i
learned two things in this story
yeah i didn't know about quarantine
originating the word originating in
venice and also what the hell is
the mask the venetian master there was a
purpose of that long nose
very interesting all right well venice
is there when you're ready i'm ready now
but
i'm not sure i'm going right away as
soon as i can